Assassin's Creed code name Jade is our
first open world RPG game on mobile
it will take you to ancient China in a
time of intrigue and conspiracy
in this brand new adventure you'll
experience the iconic Assassin's Creed
gameplay for free anywhere anytime
I am glad to announce that you can
register now for the upcoming beta
here's a glimpse of what you can expect
[Applause]
[Music]
Legacy
it's honoring those that came before us
learning from their triumphs
and mistakes
to illuminate and hold their stories to
light
for all to see
that inheritance of knowledge helps to
guide and shape our future
now it's your turn
to build on those foundations
and rise to even grade our Heights
to step out of the shadows and into a
vast world
to make your own legacy
foreign
[Applause]